let us bring in the author of a brand
new book it's called get Trump Harvard
Law Professor Alan dershowitz and the
author of the upcoming book trial of the
century Fox's legal analyst Greg Garrett
professor
there is a passion for this to happen on
the left but you are argue rightfully so
this is against the constitution of our
country
I have never seen a case in my 60 years
of practice which has so many holes in
it start with the statute of limitations
it's seven years before he committed the
crime the New York State Statute says
the only exception for that is if his
whereabouts were unknown I have to tell
you even Bragg could have found him he
was in the white house he's the easiest
and
you
ouch New York well there are photographs
of him at his house on the street he was
not continuously out of New York I don't
see how you can twist and turn to make
the statute of limitations disappear and
then you have all the other how many
holes are there shall I count the ways
to count the quote the poet I have never
seen a weaker case and in the end I
really do think Greg is worried about
his own bar card I think he's worried
that if he brings this case and he uses
a witness who he has to know is lying
they're going to be investigations of
him and there should be investigations
he holds an office that was held by Bob
morgenthau Frank Hogan some of the great
prosecutors in history and he is
disgracing that office by bringing this
case so I hope he comes to a census
doesn't bring this case in my book
get Trump you know I named the book I
didn't make up the name this the name
was made up by Leticia James and by uh
Bragg they were the ones who campaigned
on the promise of get Trump assistant
professor it's not Justice uh Greg let
me bring you in and I'm asking you to
speculate on this but the grand jury not
showing up today why did that happen and
reports of Chaos in Bragg's office I
believe they probably are true that's my
guess I don't know for sure
yeah I think it is true uh and you know
of course the mainstream media which
spent the last several days salivating
over an imminent Trump indictment today
was Crest falling when they found out
wait a minute all of a sudden the grand
jury proceedings have come to a halt I
think a couple of things are happening
here Sean you put your finger on one of
them and that is that there is a Revolt
in the district attorney's office
dissension in the ranks top senior
experienced prosecutors uh are angry
about this they see it for what it is a
politically motivated Witch Hunt a
convoluted Looney Tunes legal theory
that has no merit Brad contorted the law
Twisted the evidence because he hates
Donald Trump but I think the other thing
that as a foot here is the grand jury
itself Alan put his finger on it last
night when we were talking about it you
know I think all of a sudden the grand
jurors after Bob Costello's testimony of
money you're saying to themselves wait a
minute are we getting snookered in
sandbagged by Alan Bragg Costello comes
in here and says Michael Cohen who
brag's relying on is the biggest liar in
the world a prodigious and Veteran liar
who cannot be trusted and also I think
they were probably taken aback by the
fact that Bragg appears to have been
hiding hundreds of documents and email
cells from them that's exculpatory
evidence and they have a right to see
that and so it doesn't surprise me the
reports that you know he's having
trouble convincing now the grand jurors
to indict all right
John McLaughlin last question
predictions Professor will they vote to
in to indict Donald Trump yes or no
break a record if the grand jury
actually revolted and said we're not
going to indict a ham sandwich we're
fighting back we have seen the Evan we
the lawyers now and we're not going to
take orders we're an independent body
and we have to make sure we have to look
at ourselves in the mirror and I'm going
to break it up a little let me go to
Greg will they indict or not Greg your
prediction
well I think it's unraveling and I'd say
it's about 50 50 right about now I think
I agree with you all right straight
ahead thank you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else